let's continue on the theme here how is
it that saying basic truths
has now become not only dangerous but
something worthy of cancelling people
well you may remember a couple months
ago before i was off the grid
jordan peterson was suspended on twitter
he has been permanently banned on
twitter he ain't on the twitter anymore
god bless him uh because he said
something about
what was known as ellen page she was an
actress in x-men i thought she was
pretty good she was in a couple other
movies she was in juneau she was in
inception she was a pretty good actress
now she is elliot page and she
transitioned i suppose and you must
refer to her with her pronouns or you
will be demolished and destroyed anyway
jordan had tweet about her he got banned
i screenshot that thing i then got
banned i'm back he's gone okay there you
go but jordan is not taking it lying
down he put up a spectacular
video yesterday he's back on tour in
europe right now but he put this up i
think it's just in the last few hours uh
talking directly to twitter ceo parag
agrawal
take a look at this portion i was banned
from your platform without anything
other than a generic and self-serving
low resolution explanation
two
that my appeal of that ban was ignored
even though my repetition of the
aforesaid behavior was noted and acted
upon within hours if not minutes
three
that your company's reasons for banning
and manipulating or regulating the
behavior of your users are utterly
opaque ineffectual and self
contradictory
for
that your own security personnel and
potential investors or even purchasers
of your company have been properly
scared off by the chaos that reigns
under your authority
five that you take to yourself the moral
propriety necessary
to continue censoring a former president
of the united states even as a critical
election approaches without knowing at
all whether or not you are making even
the situation under him that you object
to worse instead of better and have
absolutely no reliable data pertaining
to that possibility and finally
six
that your careless sensorious behavior
and enabling of the anonymous
machiavellian narcissists and
psychopaths who inhabit the twitter
troll underworld is warping and
dementing the entire domain of public
discourse
hey what you mean say it clearly pretty
good jordan peterson so that is in
essence it's an open letter to the
twitter ceo now the twitter ceo of
course will not respond
we also know that twitter is now in this
legal fight with elon musk over they are
now trying to force him to buy the thing
right remember at first they didn't want
to buy the thing they were going to take
this poison pill the board was really
afraid that he was going to buy it and
create a free speech zone so they were
going to in essence destroy the entire
company then enough of the shareholders
were like whoa whoa whoa whoa when the
world's richest man wants to buy the
company at a premium price we want to
sell so then they decided to sell then
elon basically was like okay well i just
need to look at some numbers here and
does this all make sense and how many
bots are here and is this whole thing
fake i mean i am buying a business here
uh and now he found out that a whole
bunch of it's fake there are there are
uh analysts data analysts that believe
that up to eighty percent
eighty percent of the twitter attraction
might be fake elon was willing to say
i'll buy it at five percent fake uh but
eighty percent's a bridge too far but
anyway
uh the the twitter ceo obviously is not
going to respond to this and isn't it
interesting i i often think about this
you know we're all on let's say twitter
or you use gmail or you're on facebook
or whatever you can't get anyone from
these companies on the phone have any of
you guys ever gotten anyone from these
companies on the phone spoke to anyone
at these companies isn't that
interesting like would you buy a car
from a company that you could never
speak to someone on the phone maybe you
could get an emailed response but
usually just get a form letter maybe you
could get a robot in a chat but yet we
all go on gmail
we all have the suite of google products
run our businesses on these things and
there is literally nobody to talk to at
these companies do you think something
strange is going on here well in any
event jordan is still fighting and you
must still fight